Hollywood is constantly filming bizarre bits,
from space battles, to magic spells, to Nic
Cage's acting.
"Ahahaha hahaha haaaa..."
But sometimes, the strange stuff you find
in movies are there completely by accident.
Here's a look at five of the weirdest things
accidentally filmed in movies.
The hanging munchkin
During a scene in The Wizard of Oz, some viewers
noticed something upsetting going on in the
background: a dark human-shaped figure swinging
from a tree as though it had been hanged.
Rumors soon spread that one of the actors
portraying a Munchkin in the movie was depressed
over his unrequited love for a lady co-star...and
decided to hang himself in the faux woods
of the Tin Woodsman set.
"Oh, did that hurt?"
"No, it feels wonderful."
However, when MGM remastered and re-released
the movie in 1998, instead of the hanging
figure it appeared as though a large bird
was stretching its wings.
Some conspiracy theorists were convinced there
was a coverup, while others believe a simple
editing error somehow made the bird appear
to look like a human corpse in the original
version.
This is what happens when you try to look
behind the curtain!
"Pay no attention to that man behind the curtain."
The Candy Man slam
Who can smack a little girl in the chin and
get away with it?
The Candy Man can, apparently.
In the 1971 classic musical adventure Willy
Wonka and the Chocolate Factory, one of the
extras listening to the candy shop owner's
song got an unexpected surprise when he lifted
the counter-top to let the hungry children
through and accidentally smacked her in the
chin in the process.
Like a pro, the girl didn't react, but man...that
still had to hurt.
The mystery spirit
The Ring is supposed to be scary, but here's
a case of some unintentional terror, as a
shadow person's head and shoulders can be
seen slipping in and out of the lighted window
frame behind the characters in this sequence.
Chances are this was a simple case of a stagehand
being in the wrong place at the wrong time,
with the mistake not getting caught by the
editors.
However, some superstitious fans believe it's
an actual spirit accidentally caught on-screen,
which seems to happen a lot.
Maybe even in this YouTube video!
The missing masterpiece
You wouldn't ordinarily expect a family film
like Stuart Little to accidentally solve a
decades old art mystery, but that's exactly
what happened when Hungarian art expert named
Gergely Barki spotted Robert Bereny's long-lost
avant garde painting, "Sleeping Lady with
Black Vase," (incredible name) in the background
of the 1999 kids comedy.
Barki immediately recognized it as a masterpiece
that had been missing since the 1920s and
spent the next two years trying to get in
touch with someone from the movie's production
crew, only to find out they had sold it off
after filming ended.
The collector who bought it later returned
it to Budapest — 90 years after it originally
went missing — and sold it at auction in
2014 for 229,500 Euros.
Makes you think, huh?
"If we get out of this, I'm sticking to painting
and dancing."
The frozen children
Will Ferrell might've been trying to trade
in his slapstick comedy schtick for drama
with 2010's Everything Must Go.
But there was a bit of unintentional humor
in the background of one scene when a bunch
of children suddenly froze in place while
the adults continued moving and talking.
Either the child actors were told to sit still
for the shot and really nailed it, or something
went very wrong in the special effects process.
Or maybe Laura Dern's character is slyly casting
some sort of stun spell on those poor kids
with her weird hand gestures?
Creepy man…
"Stupify"
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And as always leave us a comment to let us
know which movie accident is your favorite…